Allah is taking the promise of time,
oath of
time. Verily man is in a state of loss.
Man is
in except those who have
faith. Those who have righteous
deed, those who invite people to truth,
Allah is talking about dawa. inviting
the non-Muslims to
Islam
except those who invite people to
patience and
perseverance. So these are the minimum
four criteria for any human guru Jenna.
You may be a very good Muslim. You may
be praying five times a day. You may be
fasting in the month of Ramadan. You may
be giving zakat. You may have gone
through Hajj. But if you don't do dawa
under normal circumstances, you shall
not go to Jenna. Only dawa is also not
sufficient. All four are equally
important. Righteous
deed inviting people to patient and
pursue. If anyone is missing under
normal circumstances, you shall not go
to Jenna. If Allah wants to forgive you
and put you in Jenna, that's Allah's
prerogative. But according to surah al
assur under normal circumstances if you
do not do any of these one of these four
things you shall not enter
Jenna
and
da'wah is fur conveying the message of
Islam to the non-Muslims is fur for
every
Muslim Allah says in the Quran in surah
alan chapter number three verse number
110 Allah says
Oh ye Muslims, ye are the best of
peoples evolved for mankind. Allah is
giving us Muslims and honor. And Allah
is calling us a um the best of
peoples. Whenever there is honor, it is
always followed up with a
responsibility. There is no honor
without responsibility. For example, in
a company, the CEO, the chief executive
officer has got more honor than a
manager. The manager has got more honor
than a
clerk. In the same way, the CEO, the
chief executive officer has got more
responsibility than a
manager. The manager has got more
responsibility than a clerk. There is no
honor without
responsibility. Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala in this verse of the Quran of
surah Imran 3 verse number 110 is
calling us Muslim
asmah is giving us an honor.
Don't you think we have a
responsibility? The answer is given in
the same versah
continues because we enjoying what is
good and we forbid what is wrong and we
believe in Allah. Allah is calling
us the best of peoples because we enjoy
what is good and we forbid what is wrong
and we believe in Allah. If we do not
enjoy what is good and if we do not
forbid what is wrong, we aren't fit to
be called as hram. We aren't fit to be
called as
Muslims. It is the duty of every Muslim
that he conveys the message of
Islam to the
non-Muslim. Our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said it's
mentioned hadith it's a say hadith
ofi had number
2517 once a man comes to the prophet and
asks him that should I tie my camel and
then trust in god or leave my camel and
then trust in god the prophet said tie
your camel and trust in
god what do you mean by trust in god
trust in god means we do salah we
worship Allah subhana wa t'ala what does
Allah what did the prophet mean by
saying tie tie your camel means you have
to
plan when we do
anything if you don't plan that means we
are not tying a camel if you plan means
you're tying your camel if you fail to
plan you plan to fail